louis burton achevé cette nuit un peu
après minuit son vendée globe
arrivé en deuxième aux sables d'olonne
d'arrière charlie dalin il se classe
finalement troisième
après yannick bestaven vainqueurs grâce
aux compensations obtenues pour le
sauvetage de kevin escoffier un tour du
monde en solitaire bouclé en 80 jours 10
heures 25 minutes et 12 secondes
c'est une histoire sur une dizaine
d'années qui s'écrit avec avec une
équipe qui s'écrit avec un partenaire
avec des sponsors est arrivé couper
cette ligne en deuxième place leur
offrir ça c'est une grande joie pour moi
une grande satisfaction et puis
personnellement une grande fierté
ce qu'il a fallu aller la chercher du
début à la fin cette place car tout ne
s'est pas déroulé comme prévu
tu es le premier jour louis burton est
sanctionné d'une pénalité de cinq heures
pour avoir franchi la ligne de départ de
seconde trop tôt il ne savait pas encore
que la victoire se jouerait dans un
mouchoir de poche
on sent très bien passé évidemment mais
on va essayer de se rassurer en vue donc
le vainqueur à l'échelle d'un vendée
globe c'est pas grand chose
un cafouillage dans le décompte entre
j'avais à l'ordinateur et puis que
j'entendais à la vhf
mais ce contretemps lui aura permis de
réparer son bateau et être parfaitement
affrété pour passer le cap de bonne
espérance
j'y ai cru à l'entrée de l'océan indien
en fait assez tôt dans la course
je me tiraient la bourre avec les
bateaux de tête
ensuite ça a été l'ascenseur émotionnel
tout en bas au fond du trou tout en haut
tout en bas tout en haut tout en bas
depuis le début de l'océan indien
jusqu'à il ya quelques jours encore
affaiblie par de nombreuses avaries sur
sa grande voile louis burton aura même
frôlé l'abandon nous sommes le 20
décembre
le skipper qui n'a pas dormi depuis deux
jours décide de se réfugier à l'abri des
vents forts derrière l'île macquarie un
petit archipel isolé au milieu du
pacifique
il monte sur son mât effectuer des
réparations en bravant sa peur du vide
donc maintenant on va descendre sans se
casser la figure
on va renvoyer la jv et on va lui mais
pour entrer au ca s'ensuit une remontée
qui restera dans les annales du vendée
globe de la 11e à la première position
en franchissant l'équateur pour remonter
vers les sables d'olonne
c'est une course étonnante le vendée
globe pour ça il faut être capable
d'oublier complètement ses objectifs ses
ambitions sportives et juste s'accrocher
à une chose c'est rester en vie rester
sur son bateau et puis et puis terminer
un podium accroché au bout du suspense
puisque son concurrent boris herrmann a
heurté un bateau de pêche quelques
heures avant son arrivée
l'ayant contraint à fortement ralentir
louis burton achève ainsi son deuxième
vendée globe en trois participations
il le boucle en sept jours de moins que
lors de la précédente édition en 2016